come on angela don't you have a game
i have one yes
well let's play what is it
i call it pam
i count how many times jim gets up from
his desk and goes to reception to talk
to you
we're friends
apparently done
very nicely done okay so i think that's
hor for stanley it's not a surprise to
me
pam is the office mattress
in the martin family we like to say
looks like someone took the slow train
from philly
that's code for check out the [ __ ]
why are there flies in here what color
do you guys think
well there's
green blue
yellow
red how about green
i think green is kind of [ __ ]
phyllis i need you to pick up green
streamers at lunch
i thought you said green was [ __ ]
no orange is [ __ ]
um so i had a couple of ideas to make
the stanford people feel more at home
each year we have a christmas raffle
it would never work here
okay
um another idea was
karaoke no
a christmas drinking game yes god help
you
what these are all terrible ideas and
none of them are on the theme of a
nutcracker christmas
i think you should leave
you're kidding
you tried this out it's clearly not for
you
it's time to go
come on
please thank you
okay thank you very much
listen dummy it's not that hard all you
have to do is take the numbers from the
sales report and type them into a master
spreadsheet a gt monkey could do it i do
not understand why you can't do it i
have a nice comforter and several cozy
pillows i usually read a chapter of a
book and it's lights out by 8 30. that's
how i sleep at night the man is wearing
sandals i don't need to see oscar's toes
at work gross i mean he looks like he
just got off the boat
can't you just not look at his feet
excuse me
oh
you're so educated aren't you toby so
trying to deal with a hysterical woman i
don't want to look at his feet
do your job
he loves those pants
i'll take him
please after the turtle i am enormously
proud of what i did for that turtle
oscar oscar you take him no i'm a dog
person
if you pray enough you can change
yourself into a cat person pam you know
how you and jim did your ironic wedding
do you still have the plans for the
dream wedding that you couldn't afford
that was our dream wedding
niagara falls
pregnant that was your dream
pork medallions
i hope
you have a very beautiful wedding angela
um what should we talk about
well we could talk about an ethical
dilemma i'm having
oh yeah sure um i hope i can help
a co-worker of mine is drinking caffeine
while pregnant and i don't know if i
should call social services about it
angela that's pretty transparently me
maybe
you know it's just herbal tea
and mugs with trace amounts of coffee
yeah i think you should call social
services i already did
you know maybe we should just have our
own pregnancies and not pretend like
we're in this together
fine
fine
um what should we talk about
well we could talk about an ethical
dilemma i'm having
oh yeah sure um i hope i can help
a co-worker of mine is drinking caffeine
while pregnant and i don't know if i
should call social services about it
angela that's pretty transparently me
maybe
you know it's just herbal tea
and mugs with trace amounts of coffee
yeah i think you should call social
services i already did
you know maybe we should just have our
own pregnancies and not pretend like
we're in this together
fine
fine
the shangri-la tent it's two stories
heated
and it has a bridal suite for my bridal
suite
it's just really simple really tasteful
i don't want to be married in a tent
like a hobo
hobos live in trains
nana mimi can't be in canvas that long
well nana mean
okay look
this tent is awesome
and it's in high demand so i really
think we should put a deposit down now
okay fine
you can have your tent but only if it's
in a field a hand plowed field done and
doner there has to be a barn that's old
enough that
you can see the stars through the roof
slats when you lay on your back
and antique tools to look at when you
roll over
do you have a specific place in mind
no
but anything within a five to eight mile
radius is acceptable
on it
if you ever wondered whether you were
michael scott here's a quiz to help
if you ever put sunblock on a window you
might be michael scott
i normally don't enjoy making people
laugh
if you ever called the fire department
because your head was stuck in your
chair you might be
[Laughter]
[Applause]
are you swallowing them whole you're
eating them so fast are they even
touching your tongue
yes look it's a little pregs and big
pregs
wait when did we start isn't it amazing
the difference in our sizes
well i am a few months ahead of you i'm
having a child with my husband the
senator and pam is having a child with
jim
the great salesman so how do you feel
about the fact that the banner says
lunch i feel angry
angry at you angry at you for doing
something stupid angry at me for
believing you could do something not
stupid
i'm so sorry to hear that that must be
awful it is awful you've made this day
awful
maybe you could just change the u into
an a
then it would say lance party kevin
would it really be better if it said
lance party
i asked for assorted cutlery and i got
back spoons these are worthless
i want to understand what you're saying
but it's difficult for me when you use
that tone
phyllis
these are spoons
spoons have rounded tops and are used to
scoop things
what we need are forks which have prongs
or tiny spears on top and we need knives
which have blades
do you understand me now
yes
goody
you know what hunter was a terrible
assistant that is why ryan fired well i
think he's probably just about as
reliable as pam being that it usually
takes you an afternoon to get back to me
yeah sometimes i think she holds on to
faxes
dress for the job you want not the job
you have
all right you can use your clothing to
send a message about your ambitions by
wearing clothes that reflect what you
aspire to be not gaining anything from
this seminar i'm a professional woman
the head of accounting i'm in the
healthiest relationship of my life
i just think it's insulting that jan
thinks we need this
and apparently judging from her outfit
jan aspires to be a [ __ ]
those aren't chips and dip
no i made brownies
what i'm just trying to figure out why
you're sabotaging things
i made brownies and i made cookies
same category
and we're gonna need a loaves and fishes
kind of miracle to feed them all
jesus is not your caterer
but he should be your caterer cause
you're a little angel why didn't your
parents get you a caterer
they don't think the most important
thing is that no one say anything about
my pregnancy at the wedding absolutely
because not everyone knows and some
people might be offended decent people
everywhere will get offended this is an
amazing prize i mean i don't even want
to give pam a compliment because she's
so this
but she did a good job
you